bonjour à vous vous êtes chef cuisiner
et créateur du restaurant thaï boxe
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur l'
art et france adore cette annonce du
président hier à vis à vis des
restrictions tenir encore quatre à six
semaines
comment vous l'accueillez imaginaire
je l'accueille qu'elle très très mal
parce que c'est encore des promesses
limon pas pouvoir tenir ça c'est sûr et
certain
parce que dans le sens où je pense bien
les restaurants ya pas de kobe dans les
restaurants ou pas se voiler la face si
on ouvre les centres commerciaux aussi
bondée de monde
je pense bien qu'on peut trouver les
restaurants là ça fait depuis un mois
campe l or et ça continue ça continue ça
continue
au bout d'un moment moi aujourd'hui je
suis obligé de me plaindre
monsieur je me suis là il n'ya pas très
bas très longtemps' lundi dernier où ça
m'a coûté 2 me fais virer en fait d'eux
des impôts pour les dards offre et du
tapage parce que je n'ai pas encore
touché ans comme les indemnisations
depuis de quatre poules depuis le mois
de novembre et jusqu'à ce jour je n'ai
toujours rien et c'est très très très
dur pour moi je suis en train de me
battre pour voir en fait que mon
restaurant il reste et les chiens vivent
quoi même si j'ai des messages de
partout de certains collègues de des
clients des clients ou des certains élus
mais ça suffit pas parce que là on a
besoin de risques psychologiques mans ça
ça pèse sur nous aujourd'hui je suis
public de sony fait pour pouvoir dormir
parce que c'est très compliqué car dont
denis six à quatre semaines est ce qu on
va s qui va respecter sa parole comme
nous a dit le 15 jean le 15 et le 20
janvier
on est quand même le 2 mars aujourd'hui
tout est fermé
tout est fermé alors ces quatre à six
semaines c'est une estimation selon
emmanuel macron peut-être que c'est pour
laisser le temps aux si la campagne de
vaccination
de faire effet est-ce que cela vous
semble réaliste et est ce que il ya
peut-être un espoir quand même au bout
de ces quatre à six semaines que les
restrictions soient levés
il y a pas d'espoir parce qu'
aujourd'hui la france a perdu le
gouvernement français se tournent au
gouvernement de mâcon a perdu sa
crédibilité aux yeux de tous les
restaurateurs nos yeux des français
parce que tantôt isa nom de salle pour
tous les ânes aussi ils ont mal géré la
crise sanitaire
au lieu de passer devant la télé qu'à se
para n'y en a pas a dit des chiffres des
millions on va vous aider ou on va vous
donner ça moi je ne crois pas
personnellement pour ma part je ne crois
même pas parce qu'une préparation sortie
d'une d'une crise sanitaire pauvre idée
des établissements recevant du public ça
se prépare
c'est ça on peut regarder nous voyons 42
députés ont lancé un appel afin de
pouvoir faire rouvrir les restaurant le
midi avec des conditions sanitaires
strictes pour ceux qui le demandent
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de cette
initiative
les 42 députés bas je le remercie
beaucoup franchement c'est ici très
gentil de leur part c'est vraiment fou
show vraiment vraiment que ça marche
déjà le chili mais après comment vous
ici on est dans une crise sanitaire à
cette personne qui a le pouvoir de
prendre des décisions c'est monsieur
minc ont aimé chamakh ont pour l'instant
il en a rien à de ce que j'ai moi
du terme attendait parce que quand même
le gouvernement emmanuel macron
réfléchit aussi à un pass sanitaire pour
pouvoir permettre aux personnes qui sont
qui seront vaccinés qu'ils le sont de se
rendre dans un bar ou un restaurant
cette idée là qu'en pensez vous un
patient lutte armée
vous en faites nous voyez madame je vous
dis un truc au lieu de passer patron
6000 chemin pour nous annoncer les
choses ça c'est nous français en à l'art
et la manière de se comporter comme ça
au lieu dit les choses d'une façon très
spontanée en disant voilà il y aura des
restrictions qu'on va ouvrir les
restaurants on va mettre en place un
pass à lithaire de carn été victime de
vaccination
pour que vous puissiez aller dans les
endroits publics c'est clair c'est dit
c'est net c'est limpide mais on passe
par si peut-être qu'il y aura un carnet
de vaccination pour quitter le
territoire
pt qui aura incarné des six petites pour
moi tout ça c'est du mensonge
à part le carnet de vaccination que je
suis sûr qu'ils vont mettre ça en place
si t'es pas vaccinés tu peux pas le nier
un restaurant ben moi je suis moi je
suis prêt mais à ne pas être vaccinés
parce que je ne sais je ne sais pas ce
qui ce max ce vaccin wade les risques ou
des conséquences plus tard quoi donc
vous disiez que ce serait difficile on
comprend de tenir la vente à emporter
cela représente quoi pour les
restaurateurs à ce que ça permet
justement de de payer les charges les
enfin pour tous les employés ça mais
aujourd'hui la vente à emporter
là où ça marche dans les mcdo tout ce
qu'ils fassent oui parce que eux ils ont
ils ont ils font que du sien j'allais
vous pouvez pas demander à un
restaurateur qui achètent du homard ou
de la souris d'agneau du magret de
canard ou des palourdes ou des moules ou
des huîtres j'en passe de fait de la
vente à emporter sachant que ya des
temps de de stockage parce qu'au bout
d'un moment il faut j'étais situent les
ventes a donc a longtemps porté ça
représente que dalle moi j'ai essayé moi
le premier j'ai essayé au moins neuf ans
j'ai essayé de faire de la vente à
emporter
j'ai vu que franchement sachant que moi
je suis dans un petit village par un
petit village m'a un petit bourg à 1 5
minutes de l'aéroport de nantes et j'ai
essayé ce petit cette vente à emporter
mais j'ai vu que ça me rapporte des
pages et des normes j'étais fatigué mais
puiser pour rien pour gagner des sous
que après qui en plus l'état va me taxer
encore dessus je fais mieux attendre
qu'ils vont nous dit l'ouvertue total
et puis là j'ouvre mon restaurant où je
pourrai gagner mieux ma vie donc c'est
ce que j'attends en fait la vente en
porte et ça me présenterai un casque et
entre hubert qui prend
il prend des cours sont cage des 30% sur
chaque commande ou des libéraux du
génois je travaille pas pour quelqu'un
j'ai pas décidé de nous mettre à mon
compte pour travailler pour hubert pour
délivrance assez merci beaucoup à vous
1e qu'ea voix bon courage rappelle que
vous êtes un chef cuisinier et créateur
du restaurant thaï boxe